des longs cours le ciné c'est ce qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure on continue à
parler cinéma mais à la verrière
exactement puisque ahmed mathari vous
êtes là pour représenter
vous êtes responsable de la jeunesse à
la verrière et venez vous venez
représentait donc l'événement qui
s'appelle la verrière fait son cinéma
donc il s'agit de familiariser les
jeunes et moins jeunes à l'univers du
cinéma et de la vidéo
quelque part l'idée sous jacente c'est
donc de redonner du sens à l'image à la
construction des images donc c'est une
troisième édition cette année vous
renouveler l'expérience donc à trois
temps forts donc on va démarrer
peut-être par la première date kate
aujourd'hui puisqu'il s'agit du forum
autour du cinéma donc ce sont des
ateliers notamment pour les enfants mais
pas que puisque là à l'heure où on parle
je crois que c'est tout public 1 c'est
ça wipro temps en temps pour les enfants
tant pour les jeunes et lin un temps
tout public jusqu'à 19 heures voilà donc
c'est des ateliers de maquillage de
trudeau trucage des ateliers avec on
voit les à l'image par exemple avec un
fond vert pour manipuler les
incrustations etc
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a eu un
fort succès déjà l'année dernière donc
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle vous
renouveler cette année classé premier
temps forts et le deuxième qui est
important et c'est un peu plus long
puisque ça va se dérouler donc cette
fois ci du 27 mars au dos d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'au 15 juin
c'est un concours de vidéos alors de
quel type de vidéo il s'agit quel type
de personne en fait peut-être candidat
d'accord alors pour nous donc le forum
c'est un petit peu le lancement du
concours sur ce forum fut l'important
c'est que c'est donc que les
professionnels du cinéma qui viennent à
la rencontre des publics est il allé
publics ont l'occasion de pouvoir
pratiquer de soi dont ceux du maquillage
sur de la réalisation il ya un plateau
télé qui a été montée des films
d'animation s'est mis en partenariat
avec troisième c'est l'école de cinéma
qui vient
sa talonnade qui vient de trappes qui
vient
depuis deux ans maintenant pour ce
batteur et donc ça me permet de lancer
ce fameux concours où là c'est la
troisième édition ce concours oui pour
nous le cinéma c'est un vecteur de
rencontres
c'est avec artois de rencontres trans
générationnel de l'ensemble des
quartiers on a des tout petits qui
propose des films et puis on a aussi les
maisons de quartier avec les adultes
parce que c'est donc en fait on peut
postuler en tant qu individuel ou en
tant que collectif
voilà c'est ça chacun a tout mon
possible sur un film un duel et puis
nous nos structures qui avaient les
services younès le centre de loisirs les
maisons de quartier les centres sociaux
proposent d'accompagner glace est
important il ya un accompagnement à la
fois technique et pédagogique sur la sur
le cinéma donc à des projets collectifs
l'idée provient du lieu alors on va
regarder une petite vidéo qu'a mis en
place le scarabée qui explicative assez
courte et qui est très didactique
on regarde tout de suite
or aussi fine la carrière au cinéma
voilà donc un concours avec deux prix
prix public prix jury donc pour
s'inscrire c'est le site de la verrière
par la suite on a vu un petit bandeau
s'afficher avec l'adresse du site donc
chaque participant en fait va
directement sur le site est alors enfin
le troisième temps fort donc c'est la
soirée de clôture
alors donc y aura une remise des prix
non mais de prix sar au niveau scarabée
donc l'ensemble du projet est piloté par
l'oscar b ce qui est important aussi de
se poser individuel il ya aussi l
accompagnement technique qui est
possible à travers le cyberespace donc
on a une personne qui peut accompagner
sur les techniques de montage et propose
du matériel on s'est équipé aussi en
postes multimédias donc on peut venir
individuellement mais pas seul aussi sur
la complicité tous les vidéastes
amateurs sont vraiment bien accompagné
pour proposer des projets les presque et
les plus professionnelles à travers une
formation aussi des agents d'animateurs
une formation qui est mis en place aussi
en partie par trois yes
et puis par d'autres intervenants sur le
scénario sur les techniques de tournage
le montage histoire et on suivra bien
évidemment toute cette actualité puisque
le concours va se dérouler au cours des
prochaines semaines avec cette soirée de
clôture le 28 juin vous avez la recette
va forcément jeté un coup d'oeil à ce
que vous faite puisqu'on est toujours
lancé pour le signer 7 qui est de retour
sur les rails voilà après c'est cette
fermeture et cette date officielle le 3
avril pour la réouverture merci à tous
les deux nous allons poursuivre ce cette
suite on parlait de des deux plus jeunes
par le cinéma on va voir que le théâtre
aussi peut être un vecteur pour aider l
les plus jeunes c'est un bon support
auparavant un petit agenda
aurélien et oui quelques bâches et oui
parce que ce week end c'est le week-end
de pâques
donc la chasse aux oeufs est ouverte
alors nous pouvons aller d'une première
dans un premier temps à chevreuse c'est
le château de breteuil qui propose donc
une grande chasse aux oeufs ainsi que
des animations des jeux de piste
maquillage donc c'est dimanche et lundi
entre 12h30 et 17h il est également
possible de se rendre à saint cyr et
également avec une chasse aux oeufs mais
cette fois ci une grande journée dani
nation sur le thème du cirque donc c'est
samedi 30 mars à 14 heures au parc
maurice le luc à saint cyr l'école et
pendant cet agenda deux autres invités
pour conclure cette édition nous ont
rejoints juste le temps de vous dire que
le portrait de la candidate de the voice
qui est originaire des yvelines vous le
retrouverez dans l'actu 20h30 et 22h
s'agit d'une gamme gamme voilà est-ce
que vous vous retournerez au son de sa
voix en écoutant votre télévision 20h30
22h pour ce reportage à revoir bien sûr
dans le 7 8 1 dès demain à 18h en direct
et sur notre site internet